o ato de funk que vão eo link aqui eu ia
contratar e meu colar coleta de sangue
que pelo meu sangue ser muito e 1.014
prosseguiu migas inclusive que o beijo
só vai precisar posso lançar acha achei
tranquilo para cuidar uma mãe do bebê
vamos isto pois é
hoje vai ser a minha calma primeira e
sem medalha
namora com o menino guerreiro espera se
uma amiga no clássico o jogo de hoje vai
ser uma festa mas vai ser o hospital
único gol foi uma ação é pensar a quem
possa pensar iotti são que nem todos com
lançam e catarina onde vai jogar 11 jan
ake o hospital hospital de novo mais
fechado em um ovo gae/j o primeiro
agora sim podemos jogar
agora nós não temos fome apresentado no
fio agora é que o momento posso falar
agora meu amorzinho vai acontecer é que
no jogo e tu vais tentar não buscará o
hexa é claro e banho meu dinheiro bora
lá a faca não na do meio demônios aqui
mesmo do mundo para anthony o ai eu
fiquei mais escuro peraci
não sei se a esquerda que não tem tem um
susto não há 15 anos que é avança
quero voltar a partir de agora somando
os auxílios uma ducha meu irmão eu sou
uma escuridão porque eu nunca estaria
nessa situação a minha vida e ela caiu
meu irmão não é meu nem eu ache o
flamengo no fundo cor avançando enfrenta
agora o virtual bi pegado isso resolvi
pegada sanção por trás disso olha é que
esse piso que hoje é tão fish abriu a
porta o leão porque tu estás apertar ela
aproxima a não são feitos morte pode
pode parar pode ter 500 faz favor ansa
jogou o léo volta pra quem só shannon é
agora pessoal e vamos ver um carinho
desculpem lá é é a casa mãe
a faetec e isso é mau sinal para casa
também contestou as coisas modernas
inclusive coisas boas também
às vezes uma coisa boa
quando manda de apoio é sempre bom né só
me bem por acaso eu gosto daqui a exatos
acordo com os estágios alexei que tá
aqui é um lugar tenho nada que me que
agora cheira final isso não é um morto é
um canavial
não é um caso velho eu sei por que eu
tenho que ficar pronto agora não assuste
tapetão afirmou josé manuel da saca eo
time lá né não
eu não sou eu não assisti aqui né
o piso lento taxa amor não deixasse
rocha então pitt é tão só que realmente
foi mesmo um homem em cima né eu saio eu
ando com nani já visto não tá vendo
aquela lá ele é louco e little by little
eles são cigam o cigano também bebês só
bebendo cigam o maior foco no negócio do
gás do jogo é jogo
já os times não são sinônimo de flores
não é uma construção no chão
não tem problema
amor não dá para ver sair ou frança para
trás trabalha aqui que eu tenho passado
o doutor não não vou ter que ficar aqui
nem exportar até nelinha não me guio
obrigada por salvar o acidente o barco
de nome cara de brancos nunca mais
perigoso
só isso foi o que vai estar na vida real
não é tão difícil ou 2001 e nos
comentários mas são o tipo de jogos que
querem que treinou muitas jogadas querem
tipo montanha russas querem por querem
definir se querem alguma coisa sem
torcida e vamos comentários passam pelo
canal dela também fazendo na descrição
que é sempre piano por do combate usa o
ponto é dito não não espero que vocês
não estava sol enquanto com os mega mike
favorito também em rio preto e christian
até a próxima
na próxima e leão